[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten will ich war heute den lang
ersehnten regenbogen kuchen
den hatte ich ja schon beim dreh mit dem
galileo team gemacht und heute möchte
ich euch noch mal in meiner version
einfach schritt für schritt zeigen wer
geht denn bei dem dreh habe ich ja nicht
so viel zeit und dieser regenbogen
kuchen sieht von außen also die optik
sondern optik das heißt ein farbverlauf
drin von unten nach oben und innen wenn
man den anschneidet wieder richtig toll
aussehen das sieht aus wie ein
schachbrett also richtig kunterbunt
perfekt für die kinder geburtstagsfeiern
oder einfach mal so für zwischendurch
wenn man die stadt was bundesverfassung
und ich zeige euch jetzt gleich die
zutaten ich pack das ganze jetzt in 20
cm förmchen bei mir ist es so ich habe
zwei backöfen das heißt ich kann halt
immer zwei formen gleichzeitig in einen
backofen stecken und kann gleichzeitig
42 gebacken
wenn ihr das jetzt nicht machen könnt
macht ihr den teig am besten immer nach
und nach damit er nicht so lange stehen
muss und dann eben die luft nicht
ausgeschlagen und deswegen wundert euch
jetzt nicht dass die zutaten mit so
komisch da stehen ich mache dir nämlich
auch auf zweimal weil ich insgesamt
sechs böden backe und deswegen zeige ich
durchaus grund also für den teig brauche
ich sechs eier 300 gramm zucker eine
prise salz und etwas vanille extrakt ich
nehme noch die schale von 2 bio zitronen
dann habe ich 300 milliliter öl das ist
geschmacksneutrale sonnenblumenöl ich
habe 300 milliliter mineralwasser 500
gramm je 600 gramm mehl ich hab's mir
neu aufgeteilt dann habe ich 150 g
speisestärke und 1,5 päckchen backpulver
also eineinhalb genau und ich mache
jetzt erstmal die menge für vier
teigboden wird deswegen lasse ich den
rechner einfach stehen so ernst kommt
jetzt kommen jetzt die einigung der
rührschüssel wenn das kennt ihr ja schon
ich mache ganz oft den teig nach dieser
methode etwas salz rein und vanille
extrakt
[Musik]
und den zucker gleich mit rein und dann
wird es richtig schön cremig gerührt und
in der zeit kann ich schon mal die
formel mit backpapier einschlafen
[Musik]
und wenn es dann richtig schön cremig
ist gebe ich noch wasser und öl mit dazu
und lässt das kurz bei niedriger stufe
einrühren und den derzeit kann ich dann
schon mal die zitronenschale abhalten
[Musik]
dann gebe ich noch bisschen
zitronenschale mit rein jetzt nicht
alles denn ich habe ja gleich noch den
anderen tag den ich machen muss und kann
dann auch schon im trockenen zutaten 17
jetzt kurz so schnell einfach den löffel
ab werke darunter sind topfit und dann
einfach alles rein geben so ergeben so
gibt's halt im leben und der teig schön
locker und dann wird es auch kurz
unterkühlten niedriger stufe einfach nur
so lange bis sich eben alles verbunden
hat und jetzt funktioniere ich meinen
teil ich habe jetzt die vierfache menge
gemacht als er für vier portionen
deswegen 14 kleine schälchen die sollten
aber groß genug sein dass eben der ganze
tag rein passt und vor allem so dass ihr
das eben noch rühren könnt denn gleich
kommt ja noch farbe mit drin
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich meine lebensmittel
verpasste und färbt die tiger ein und
zwar mache ich von unten nach oben mache
ich einmal und lila dann in blau also
ein türkis und grün gelb auf orange und
pink rot und das geht am besten hat mir
zum verpassten denn ansonsten bekommt
ihr einfach diese intensive farbe auch
nicht hin
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich die vorbereiteten
farben also den teich ist immer auch ein
teig kann ich dann einfüllen und dann
werden die gebacken und zwar bei 160 bis
170 grad für ungefähr zwanzig minuten
ich werde auf jeden fall nach 20 minuten
die stäbchen probe machen und wenn sie
gar sind nehme ich dann den teig
rauslassen komplett abkühlen und dann
sehen wir uns gleich wieder erwartet
orte zusammensetzen
[Musik]
die trockenen böden sind jetzt gebacken
und abgekühlt ich habe es ja dann noch
in frischhaltefolie eingeschlagen
einzeln und habt ihr noch mal kurz in
den kühlschrank gegeben
der teig ist übrigens auch super dafür
geeignet dass man einfriert und dann
einfach wieder auftaut und so wenn ihr
mal sonst eigentlich habt könnt ihr den
gern einfrieren und bei bedarf wieder
auftauen und ich werde jetzt euch noch
die zutaten zeigen welche ich für die
füllung brauche denn ich möchte das
datei gibt es auch ein bisschen saftiger
wird also der erste schon schön saftig
aber noch etwas saftiger und deswegen
werde ich ihn trinken und zwar mit vier
bis fünf esslöffel aprikosenmarmelade
das ist eine ohne stückchen also eine
ganz fein püriert
dann nehme ich die zwei zitronen davon
dem saft und das vergleich damit und
dann nehme ich als creme nämlich wieder
diese frischkäse buttercreme da brauche
ich 400 gramm weiche butter 400 kampf
frischkäse und 400 gramm puderzucker und
ich hab mir jetzt hier so eine skizze
gemacht für meine torte denn ich möchte
gleich diese schachbrett optik und dafür
müssen wir jetzt gleich die teige
ausstechen und daneben zusammensetzen
und ich habe mir die skizze gemacht
damit ich später dann keinen teig habe
oder irgendwie zwei gleiche farbe
nebeneinander liegen oder so deswegen
jetzt habe ich hier so ein teig ring und
noch ein dessert in der hat jetzt glaube
ich 14 cm durchmesser und der mist so
etwa fünf haben müsste einfach mal
gucken was am besten passt dann werden
die nämlich einmal ausgestochen
[Musik]
wenn der teig gleich mit hoch geht
einfach weg setzen
das ist super
[Musik]
die tiger habe ich jetzt ausgestochen
und lasse jetzt einfach hier kurz stehen
und werden derzeit schon mal die
buttercreme zu bereiten
dafür nehme ich den puderzucker und die
butter war ständig die artikel
vertauscht und verrührt es jetzt kurz
mit einem schneebesen geht natürlich
jetzt auch in der küchenmaschine aber
ich kann es jetzt nicht dahin gemacht
und davon da steht alles wohl dass wege
machen wir das jetzt mit dem
[Musik]
also mit einem handbohrer ging es doch
nicht mit einem normalen android
funktioniert das aber mit einem
schneebesen hat leider sagt ich habe
deswegen machen wir das ist doch hinter
küchenmaschine kurz und wenn sich das
dann schön verbunden hatten schön weiß
cremig ist gebe ich noch den frischkäse
mit dazu und werden auch kurz ein
diese creme stelle ich ganz kurz zur
seite
denn so erst möchte ich hier brauchte
diese aprikosen tränke machen muss und
das mache ich einfach damit ein bisschen
geschmack in die torte kommt und eben
auch feuchtigkeit einfach dem
zitronensaft mit zur aprikosenmarmelade
pressen und dann wird das ganze noch
kurz verhüllt damit schön homogen ist
ihr könnt jetzt natürlich auch andere
geschmäcker mit reinbringen ich bin halt
zitronen liebhaberin deswegen
zitronensaft aber ihr könnt auch zum
beispiel orange nehmen oder irgendeinen
anderen sagt ich will halt jetzt keine
nehmen der farbstoff hat also nichts
rotes wie johannisbeere oder so denn es
würde er dann die farbe der tortenböden
auch verändern also irgendwas neutrales
wenn keine kinder mit essen könnte auch
in alkohol oder sowas nehmen
wobei ich zitrone immer super finden gut
und jetzt wird die torte zusammengesetzt
und die ganzen einzelteile gemacht
[Musik]
nämlich mit creme und geht anhand einer
skizze vor und zwar fange ich unten an
außen mit einem lila einen ring dann
kommt gelb rhein und in die mitte grün
also den lianen äußeren rahmen habe ich
mir schon mal auf ne konnten retter
gelegt und jetzt nehme ich mir immer
etwas creme mit der palette und streicht
es die rinnen und den rand dann ist
gleich der zweite besucher neben
anklicken kann wenn man es nämlich nicht
macht und später die torte zusammensetzt
dann fällt die halt auseinander beim
anschnitt
also wenn man denn dann schneidet dann
fangen die einzelnen würfel aus indem
man uns vor behindert
[Musik]
dann nehme ich den zweiten ring das ist
jetzt in dem fall der gelbe müssen wir
vorsichtig sein wenn er mal reist oder
bricht das ist nicht schlimm das klebe
man dann einfach wieder zusammen
der kommt jetzt da rein dann wieder
creme
[Musik]
und stand den mittleren jetzt seht ihr
hier schon deutsche zum kleiner
höhenunterschied drin ist weil ich die
tage jetzt vor dem auseinander schneiden
jetzt nicht irgendwie gleich hoch
geschnitten habe das ist aber nicht
schlimm denn ich mache das jetzt einfach
so
den überschuss weg denn wenn ich das
jetzt macht dann sitzt die torte später
schief aufeinander und das wollen wir
nicht
[Musik]
und dann setze ich den ersten tag direkt
auf eine tortenplatte und dann nehme ich
die aprikosenmarmelade mit dem
zitronensaft und trinkt desto bisschen
[Musik]
und während jetzt diese tränke hier ein
bisschen einziehen kann kann ich schon
mal die anderen böden zusammensetzen und
so mache ich das jetzt einfach anhand
der skizze weiter also die verschiedenen
einzelnen böden zwischendurch mache ich
diese platte auch immer wieder sauber
damit ich keine krümmel drauf habt denn
das sieht später in der fertigen porte
nicht so schön an zu kurz zu machen und
dann geht es wieder weiter
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich etwas weiß creme auf dem
trockenboden verteilen grad so ein
bisschen was damit auch da die einzelnen
schichten schön zusammenkleben und aber
auch damit es schöner aussieht also
gestand später wie so ein rahmen um die
einzelnen würfel herum
[Musik]
dann setze ich da den zweiten boden raum
und der wird jetzt auch wieder getrennt
mit der aprikosen zitronen tränke und
dann geht es einfach immer so weiter bis
wir alle tortenböden aufgebraucht haben
[Musik]
die torte setzt zusammengesetzt und die
meiste arbeit ist jetzt auch schon getan
ich muss jetzt noch eine weiße schicht
darüber geben und zwar bindet die
geschichte ganzen krümel und bildet
einfach nochmal so die grundlage für
diese schöne ombre schicht also mit dem
farbverlauf und deswegen streiche ich
das jetzt hier kurz ganz dünn auf also
an der oberfläche aber auch an den
seiten
[Musik]
die tochter habe ich jetzt noch mal kühl
gestellt denn diese erste schicht muss
jetzt erst mal fest werden so etwa 15
bis 20 minuten und die zeit nutze ich
jetzt um schon mal die restliche
buttercreme einzufärben und ich nehme
dafür wieder diese passten farben
ich habe vorhin übrigens beim teig zwar
auch diese de cuba farben benutzt
allerdings habe ich beim king dieses
andere pink genommen was sich auch bei
mir im job habe und zwar ist es sehr
intensiv und halt ein dunkles bringt und
ich so ein rosa wir jetzt bei den d
kovac farben und das fli da habe ich
auch von denen benutzt weil es einfach
kein flieger gibt und ich mir das ist
schlecht aus dem blau und stimmen
mischen kann also die deckung backwaren
wir sind alle zufrieden sind die
kennzeichnungspflichtigen azofarbstoffe
nicht mit drin
bei den zwei sind sie mit drin zwar
unter dem grenzwert was hier was sie in
deutschland gibt aber ja also für die
zwei kam habe ich das dann nicht mit
benutzt
und jetzt muss ich mir die farben
einfach kurz an
stell dir kriegen dann auch noch kurz
kühl und stand den wir uns gleich wieder
wenn ich die torte verdächtigungen
[Musik]
die torte ist jetzt abgekühlt und jetzt
kann ich sehr von außen dekorieren und
jetzt starte ich unten also hier ganz
unten am rand mit dem lila ton und
deswegen nehme ich da auch die lieder
buttercreme und streicht die einfach so
weit wie eben auch als zu breit wie
jeder tortenboden eben auch so ungefähr
15 cm sind
[Musik]
den überschuss dinge könntest du auch
gerne mit der palette wieder ein
bisschen wegnehmen so der übergang zu
dem blau muss jetzt auch nicht komplett
perfekt sein denn wir streichen das
später noch ineinander hat sich streicht
es dann noch schön glatt und verblendet
das schön
dann nehme ich die zweite creme und die
kommt dann direkt drüber
[Musik]
das habe ich die ränder und die
oberseite komplett damit bestreichen und
jetzt muss ich noch hier so die
übergänge schön verstreichen und zwar
nehmen die vermieter die palette immer
sauber machen zwischendurch als ich habe
ja auch im tuch was ich dann später
einfach in die waschmaschine schmeißt
und kann es dann damit sauber machen
jetzt fahre ich immer hier über diese
hypothese die heißen das wort über
diesen übergang genau und dann streiche
ich die creme ab und dann geht es weiter
du hast den projekten geholfen
[Musik]
und so stelle ich die torte jetzt erst
noch mal kühl damit die buttercreme auch
schönen fest wetten haben so etwa für 30
bis 60 minuten und danach können wir sie
auch direkt anschneiden
wer möchte kann jetzt hier oben drauf
natürlich noch über zucker streusel
geben oder ein paar smarties habe ich
finde die torte ist so schön bunt genug
deswegen lasse ich das auch endeffekt
und wir sehen uns gleich wieder damit
die torte anschneiden
die torte ist schön abgekühlt und jetzt
werde ich sie einmal an schneiden damit
ihr sie auch von innen sieht denn das
ist ja das ganz besondere an der torte
deswegen einfach irgendwo ansetzen und
ich mache dann auch das messer immer
wieder sauber
damit ich halt keine bunten krümel dann
auf der oberfläche der torte habe
dickeres stück also so ein stück kann
man nicht essen man muss schon döner
schneiden aber jetzt zum zeigen mache
ich das ist ein dicker die spannung
steigt
[Musik]
und so sieht dann die regenbogen torte
aus lienen und am ende den teller jetzt
so und schwupps dann passiert ein
missgeschick
und ich finde es ist eine richtig tolle
überraschung scorte also ich meine von
außen sieht sie ja schon gut aus wenn
man sieht von außen nur weiß
einstreichen würde wenn der effekt sogar
noch größer dieser überraschungseffekt
aber so finde ich sie sogar noch
hübscher somit den farben außen und
innen so richtig schön farbenfroh kann
man auf jeden fall mal zwischendurch mal
machen wenn man genug zeit hat es dauert
schon als ich schätze mal arbeitszeit
lag schon bei 90 minuten plus backzeit
plus wartezeit im kühlschrank
also muss man sich schon genug zeit
einplanen aber ich finde es sich auf
jeden fall ein hingucker vor allem wenn
wir mal ein kind überraschen möchte oder
auch ein großes kind ich glaube da freut
sich einfach jeder über diese torte und
ihr könnt das rezept gerne nachmachen
die zutaten schreibe ich euch nochmal
auf den block auf sally blog.de und ich
würde mich freuen wenn ihr euch daran
traut ist es nicht schwierig ist sich
nur ein bisschen aufwendiger also
zeitaufwendiger und so ein bisschen
kinder viel arbeit aber ich denke dass
ich macht war für jeden und ja es ist
eine tolle idee
ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß dabei
und freue mich wenn ihr auch das nächste
mal wieder einschaltet bis dann
[Musik]